[Aplausos]
[Música]
Viktor Orban se ha convertido en el
Johnny Depp de la política europea el
primer ministro de Hungría lleva mucho
tiempo llamando la atención de Bruselas
y del resto de capitales europeas y no
precisamente por su simpatía al húngaro
ya solo le ríes las gracias en Polonia
durante años ahora se le ha permitido de
todo la europea desde dejar que se haga
con todo el poder hasta ver como el
propio Gobierno húngaro
[Música]
el problema para urban es que ahora
tantos años de excesos comienzan a
pasarle factura su última decisión sobre
prohibir a menores todo aquel contenido
que se considere que promueve la
homosexualidad está haciendo algo así la
gota que colma el vaso Bruselas parece
ahora decidida a tomarse la cuestión de
Orban muy pero que muy en serio y me
diréis pero a ver que están pensando en
prohibir van a censurar a Will y Grace
pues para que sabes ni idea ni Harry
Potter parece que se salvaría de la
censura de Orban todo esto ha hecho que
empieza el político nos hagamos unas
cuantas preguntas que si Monjos busca el
gobierno húngaro están fundamentadas las
críticas contra urban qué papel puede
jugar la Unión Europea y quizás la más
importante de todas que puede pasar en
el futuro hoy en visualpolitik vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
urban el acción contra el comunismo
[Música]
hubo un tiempo en el que Viktor Orban
fue todo un símbolo de la lucha por la
libertad corrían los años 80 del pasado
siglo y Hungría aún era un régimen
comunista bajo la influencia de la Unión
Soviética amigos en aquel entonces el
bloque del Este ya estaba empezando a
desmoronar
[Música]
[Risas]
[Aplausos]
efectivamente el régimen socialista
soviético cayó y Fidel se convirtió en
un partido político pero
no les fue nada bien así que giro de
timón urban abandono su posicionamiento
liberal para convertir Alcides en el
gran partido de la derecha conservadora
de Hungría y sabéis que funcionó
[Música]
1998 Orban se convirtió en el primer
ministro de Hungría con primer mandato
de cuatro años con buenos datos
económicos y que avanzo en la
modernización pues comunista de Hungría
incluso su buen hacer llamó la atención
del Partido Popular Europeo la
agrupación de partidos de centro derecha
en el Parlamento Europeo casi que fueron
a Budapest para convencer a urban de que
su sitio estaba con ellos y no con los
liberales
y así es como el Fides íntegro en el
Partido Popular Europeo la vida sonreía
Orban salvo por un pequeño inconveniente
perdió las elecciones para revalidar su
gobierno y en 2006 las volvió a perder
toca da un nuevo giro de timón en la
forma de hacer política desde ese
momento mucho más radical combativa y
por qué no decirlo
populistas
[Música]
y cuando recupero el poder en 2010 lo
hizo a lo grande lo hizo con una super
mayoría de dos tercios del Parlamento
con poder suficiente para cambiar a su
antojo la Constitución y como bien
sabéis vosotros jóvenes demócratas del
mundo que nos estáis viendo ese es el
peor superpoder que se le puede dar a un
político porque desde entonces desde
Hungría solo nos llegan noticias cómo
está
sobre las amenazas a la independencia
judicial dirigiendo el gobierno desde su
cargo de primer ministro y el Parlamento
con esa super mayoría de dos tercios
urban siempre ha tenido la justicia en
su punto de mira para empezar creo una
Oficina Nacional de la Judicatura con
capacidad para vetar los accesos
judiciales e influir en el reparto de
casos que los jueces plantan cara al
gobierno pues les adelanto de golpe 8
años la edad de jubilación que el
Tribunal Constitucional sigue dando
guerra pues nada amplio el número de
magistrados y reservo vacantes para más
afines al fin es el caso es que de una
forma u otra Viktor Orban parece tener
siempre la última palabra
[Aplausos]
la separación de poderes en Hungría ha
ido perdiendo fuerza progresivamente
cada vez que pides a utilizado su súper
mayoría para brindar la agenda de
Fernando la Constitución pero es que
además el dominio de la democracia
[Música]
babas y consulados para votar
facilidades para uno y dificultades para
otros no hay pucherazo ni se líquida a
los líderes de la oposición pero es que
Alba ni siquiera le hace falta
[Música]
muchos periódicos críticos han cerrado y
fideos ha transformado la EMT y la
agencia pública de noticias del país en
un órgano de propaganda cuyo servicio
para columnas gratuito vamos que esto
acabado con las agencias de noticias
competidoras privadas simple y
llanamente con la estrategia es más
antigua de la política competencia
desleal pagada con dinero público y
claro como podéis imaginar los
periódicos más pequeños los regionales
todos se surten en gran medida de
noticias de esta agencia gubernamental
por supuesto siempre favorable al
gobierno y con la radio si las
televisiones pues pasa prácticamente lo
mismo ya lo ves urban lo tiene todo bajo
control pero espérate un momento amigos
por las cosas han cambiado desde que en
marzo pasara esto
Spider-Man deja el grupo parlamentario
del Partido Popular Europeo antes de ser
expulsado
de formar parte del grupo político que
domina el Parlamento y que tiene la
mayor capacidad para marcar el camino a
la Comisión Europea
Europea
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para los húngaros con el enemigo
comunista pues es algo que va perdiendo
tirón y justo aquí es donde sale a
reducir el olfato político de Orban qué
hay que hacer para seguir en el poder
pues está claro no si la Unión Soviética
caído pues habrá que buscar un nuevo
enemigo fabriquemos un nuevo enemigo y
tal y como decimos por aquí dicho y
hecho
recordáis la crisis de los refugiados de
hace unos años pues esta fue la
principal aportación de Viktor Orban
siquiera su país más de inmigrantes
indocumentados del Medio Oriente está
importando terrorismo crimen
antisemitismo y homofobia Viktor Orban
no sé
más allá de los prejuicios que contienen
declaraciones como está no parece que
sea la mejor forma de que un líder
político aborde una crisis de refugiados
derivada de una cruenta guerra civil
incluso aunque no esté de acuerdo con
dar cobijo a esas personas un poquito de
humanizar el caso es que Orban construyó
una barrera de alambre de púas en la
frontera para evitar que los refugiados
entrarán en Hungría todo en defensa de
lo que le dé lugar o considera una
contrarrevolución dirigida contra los
que mandan en Bruselas para reivindicar
el carácter cristiano de Europa y ha
puesto se ha ido iba a quedar todo
urbana atacado repetidamente al inversor
estadounidense George Soros como símbolo
de la globalización Soros dueño de la
Universidad centroeuropea la más
prestigiosa de Hungría y que ha
expulsado del país por promover los
valores que no coinciden con los del
gobierno y muchos estáis pensando a ver
igual es un poquito excéntrico señalar
como enemigo público número uno de
Hungría a un señor que vive en Nueva
York bueno pues puede ser pero mientras
los que no están preocupados
enfrentándose con supuestos enemigos con
vosotros o los pobres refugiados los
informes de la ola la Oficina Europea de
lucha contra el fraude y el gobierno
húngaro está perdiendo el tiempo
datos del aula sobre las irregularidades
en el uso de los fondos de la Unión
Europea golpea un día de nuevo todo
apunta a que el fin es a hecho rico a su
círculo más cercano gracias al dinero
venido de Europa y muchos diréis pero
bueno ahora mayoría de la gente no le
suele gustar que los políticos metan la
mano en la caja como es que le siguen
votando
encontramos el segundo motivo por el que
los húngaros votan a Orban
y es que lo cierto es que mientras ha
estado de primer ministro
ha progresado ronda el 4% lo que es
música para los oídos de los húngaros
que devolvieron al poder ahora van en
plena crisis de la Gran Recesión además
la Hungría de Orban ha crecido a un 3 %
de media hasta la llegada de la pandemia
de la covid-19 tiene esto mérito pues
depende si por ejemplo tenemos en cuenta
que cada año Hungría reciben ayudas
europeas el equivalente a cerca del 3%
de su PIB pues hombre muy mal tendría
que gestionar uno de los países que más
dinero recibe de la Unión Europea mirar
[Música]
para meterse tanto con los que mandan en
Bruselas no está nada mal eh de todas
formas hablaremos de la economía húngara
en un próximo vídeo así que ya sabéis
suscribiros para estar al tanto
estos amigos es que el finde es podría
estar a punto de perder el control de la
actuación tras la llegada de la pandemia
ya os hemos contado que ya no forma
parte del Partido Popular Europeo el
grupo más numeroso del Parlamento
Europeo pero es que además otros países
están hartando de los ataques de Orban a
Bruselas y de ver como el dinero de los
contribuyentes europeos se lo están
llevando a manos llenas los colegas del
primer ministro húngaro así que en las
negociaciones de los fondos para la
recuperación post pandemia los
europarlamentarios introdujeron
exigencias nunca vistas hasta ahora me
acuerdo alcanzado para vincular la
financiación de la Unión Europea con el
respeto del Estado de derecho
[Música]
Orban el estratega electoral
Hungría ha protagonizado muchas noticias
durante la pasada Eurocopa lo malo es
que fue más por motivos políticos que
por éxitos deportivos el gobierno de
Viktor Orban acaba de aprobar la ley que
prohíbe la exposición de los menores de
edad a cualquier contenido que de
visibilidad a la homosexualidad la
indignación fue enorme buena parte de
Europa y la Eurocopa fue el escenario en
el que Orban encontró la expresión más
popular de rechazo comunitario a su
legislación homófoba recordar que Munich
quiso iluminar su estadio con los
colores de la bandera arcoiris y que el
portero de Alemania lucio un brazalete
con estos colores en el partido que
enfrentó contra Hungría un gesto similar
protagonizó el piloto Sebastian Vettel
en el Gran Premio de Hungría de Fórmula
1 lo cierto es que muchos gobiernos
europeos y la propia Comisión Europea
tienen ganas a Orban hace unos años
intento actuar contra el gobierno
húngaro desde el Parlamento no pasa nada
sin embargo amigos ahora la situación es
distinta
[Música]
cuando en 2018 el Parlamento Europeo
decidió poner en marcha las canciones
del artículo 7 contra Hungría se topó
con un obstáculo insalvable la decisión
debía tomarse por consenso del resto de
países miembros de la Unión Europea una
misión imposible ante la alianza
Budapest Varsovia sin embargo las cosas
han cambiado con el nuevo reglamento
de Justicia de la Unión Europea tiene
que dar el visto bueno a la legalidad de
esta nueva exigencia para recibir dinero
comunitario
[Música]
parece que retrasara un par de años el
plazo para que la Comisión Europea fuera
plantar cara a los países miembros con
vocación y desde luego todavía es pronto
para saber si esto quedará en la típica
regulación que tanto gusta en Bruselas
reglas estrictas para contentar a los
más exigentes de una aplicación muy
flexible para tranquilizar a los
críticos la presidenta de Eslovaquia
tiene las mismas dudas
Viktor Orban pinzas que cada país tiene
que ser soberano para decidir su camino
sea cual sea este puedes dejarnos tu
respuesta en los comentarios si este
vídeo te resulta interesante el botón de
like y suscribirte si aún no lo has
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]